aurélie guichard effectué plusieurs
trajets par semaine pour les chercher
ses deux enfants la maternelle située à
5 km de l'école sont un mot ne
bénéficient pas le soir du ramassage
scolaire au quotidien elle doit jongler
avec son emploi du temps professionnel
et celui de ses quatre enfants
pour moi je fais c'est discriminatoire
parce que concrètement on doit gérer nos
emplois par rapport à l'école qui est
obligatoire donne pas les moyens pour le
faire
la faute à un déplacement d'arrêt de bus
situé les années précédentes au bord de
cette route départementale
il a été déplacé trois cents mètres plus
loin au coeur du hameau pour des raisons
de sécurité désormais situé à moins de
trois kilomètres de l'école pour le
conseil régional
il n'y a donc plus que d'obligations de
ramassage scolaire nous avons appliqué
deux principes sur l'ensemble du
territoire bourguignon franc comtois
premièrement le respect des règlements
de chaque département et là il ya une
prise en charge qui ne peut pas se faire
s'il y en arrêt à une distance de moins
de 3 km et deuxième principe la sécurité
on ne peut pas traverser des routes
départementales
quand la signalétique ne le permet pas
et donc ce deuxième principe de la
sécurité c'est celui qui a été mis en
avant et qui effectivement peut poser
problème dans certains cas pourtant la
région facture ce service aux parents
d'élèves de la longue ray l'année
dernière plusieurs d'entre eux ont donc
tout simplement refusé de payer
l'année dernière on a reçu les factures
donc 200 euros pour mes deux enfants
mais j'ai jamais le bus donc je n'ai pas
payé je paierai a service qui n'est pas
mis les parents d'élèves espèrent que
leurs enfants pourront bénéficier du
ramassage scolaire tout au long de la
journée
quant au conseil régional il promet de
travailler sur l'harmonisation des
règles en vigueur dans les différents
départements